[Music]
hey you guys happy Saturday it's a
sidetrack show yeah we thought we almost
lost the Internet we thought we you guys
weren't even gonna have any shows for
the next couple days
we're trying to figure out what [ __ ] how
are we gonna upload because I checked
the router and the router said when it
had to them red lights on our couch
would have said but couldn't get
Internet
yeah we've said over and over again I
called AT&T they tried to talk to it and
they said to the router this is it we're
not seeing it and they said that they
couldn't send anybody out till Tuesday
right and I was like and the shitty
thing too is I can't even cuz I use um
wondershare filmora for my like video
editing and it's like I found out when I
was trying to like edit one of the
episodes that I can't even export it
because it can't access the Internet
like for my account so it's like I can
export it but it'll have like [ __ ]
watermarks and [ __ ] all over it
cuz it'll think that I have a free trial
cuz it doesn't know who I am right and I
was like yay fantastic so I can't
literally cannot get a single [ __ ]
thing done yeah so we were without
internet for a couple hours yeah we were
flipping and I went to go transfer
something from the refrigerator inside
the house to the refrigerator out in the
garage and the refrigerator was off and
so is the air Casey I was like what the
[ __ ]
check the circuit breaker and tripped it
and went back out there and we had Wi-Fi
was back green lights but the stupid
thing is it wasn't like it you know it's
a trip to breaker but the nurse the
Wi-Fi router was still on because the
lights were on they were just red yeah
and everything on that TV everything on
that router and the TV was plugged into
one wall socket and it was getting power
so don't ask me how how that circuit
breaker affected that wall socket no I
don't know I don't get it it's super
weird yeah but we were just like cuz I
was sitting there going kill me kill me
oh my god because it's like not only the
show but it's like I can't get any
graphic design work I can't defend
anybody their stuff when it's done I
can't do research for my book I can't do
anything I literally can't do anything
with it
I just can't figure it out so that's a
problem at some poltergeist [ __ ]
probably it's I can't figure maybe
that's what it is I can't figure out how
the garage breaker being tripped effects
anything from that in the den because
it's just that's just it's not on that
breaker
maybe it's like maybe it's connected to
something else and it I mean it was a
powered it was losing power then why was
the TV on why was there why was their
power to the router it goes yeah yeah
we're now I'm BOTS on that musket Maseca
which is this the the Massa to make
tortillas so today we bought that yeah I
went made some corn tortillas about that
big around man they're [ __ ] are so
good they are very good you did good
like they're just doing them the first
time yeah and I made them by hand yeah
between two pieces of wax paper I didn't
have a tortilla press I just put some
wax paper down on the my little working
surface put the ball of masa put another
piece of wax paper took a big pizza pan
pressed on it real hard came out about
that big around it's a little thick but
it's alright man the flavor is really
good it's a lot better than a
store-bought pre-made corn tortilla
better I want I ate one of the tabs like
okay now I get it
well ever you know yeah one pretty much
everything you make from scratch is
gonna be better than what you get at the
store like almost always what do you
what are you gonna make with them you
make a pork taco sir yeah like yeah like
a fajita slash tostada
all right cook them I got a pre-made and
I'll recoup the shells and put them on
there but I'm marinating meat and gonna
cook up some rice Spanish rice probably
put some I'm gonna make a salsa I got
those peppers and I got some rose onions
and probably just season it then put
some garlic in it that's something on me
we've hope we haven't eaten much today I
think that I think I had one packet
oatmeal I'm like a tiny little piece of
leftover pizza there was like six inches
I had that shrimp it could have done
that but I've already got the oh yeah I
forgot about that
Oh will do will do that no time yeah
yeah
lockdowns are Endon so we're still gonna
keep we're still gonna keep sidetracks
it's just that it won't be every day
yeah it's obviously every day yeah I was
gonna say I probably won't put up a side
tracks tomorrow because the the matinee
show is going up which will actually
probably be the last matinee show that
has three movie reviews cuz we already
recorded it so I'm just gonna put that
up tomorrow although if you're a patron
you've already seen it cuz it went up
this morning but so I probably won't do
a sidetracks tomorrow unless like
something earth-shattering happens that
we feel like we have to talk about
Monday we'll probably do a movie review
because we've seen because we saw a new
movie documentary actually that we
rented and we can talk about that and I
think there's a new series on shudder
like a miniseries like a sci-fi one we
haven't watched it yet but it looked it
had like good reviews and [ __ ] so we
might review that to like later in the
week
also another heads up just because I
don't have enough [ __ ] technical
issues we've recorded our episode our
main episode last night and for whatever
reason we're recording it like the first
half because we do them in like two
halves and like in the middle we just go
and refill drinks go to the bathroom or
whatever and it's like the first half
recorded just fine
I had a little bit of audio glitching
and I had to like you know adjust it and
everything but it's not that noticeable
but for whatever reason when we started
recording the second half the program
switched from the yeti microphone to the
max internal microphone yeah so the
first half of the show
sounds like usual usually does and then
the second half sounds like kind of
shitty like it's kind of tinny
not that good you know it's because
you'll hear it though it's still
listenable like you can still listen to
it without it being too annoying but it
definitely does sound like shitty so I
apologize for that probably wouldn't
sound too good on headphones but
probably not like just you know I tried
to like tone it down because like if we
start talking loud or if we laugh or
something it kind of goes like you like
it kind of makes this horrible sound but
I'm just like warning you guys it's not
but it's like the second half does it's
not gonna sound that good because for
whatever reason it switched my
microphone I don't know why it did that
but you know that's what are you gonna
do so do we have anything else
right now yeah I think all we did last
night after we recorded the show was
watched a little bit of joe bob was was
live because he's live on Friday nights
on shutters so we were watching part of
that he was doing Exorcist 3 so we
watched a little bit of that and then I
was really stay awake any longer
yeah we've seen that a couple times past
oh wait yeah we've reviewed it not too
long ago now that I'm thinking about it
but yeah so well probably like I said
probably won't do a sidetracks tomorrow
but the matinee show is going up
tomorrow and then we'll probably do a
movie reveal on Monday so don't be
alarmed if we don't do a sidetracks
tomorrow just you know we're still alive
and everything like that but anyway have
a good rest of your Saturday and we'll
talk to you next time